you may remember we did 407 which is
about
dividing okay and then we sort of
skipped over to 409 because i wanted to
show you how to do some stuff with
calculators
so that's why we're coming back to 408
okay
now i want you to have a look at
question 13 with me that's the example
that i'm going to go through on the
board
i'm going to do it twice i'm going to do
it a bad way a way that i don't
recommend you do it to indicate that i
will do it in red
and then i'll do it the way that i think
you should do it i'll do that in blue
okay
so for now just put your pens down and
your calculators down and let's
uh watch while we go through this
question okay
read with me one sixth of the class were
a day late with their assignments
okay a sixth sixth
they were a day late with their
assignments keep going
the rest handed them in on time the rest
the rest what's the rest if one sticks
were late what's the rest
high six good okay five six
we're late oh sorry we're on time
twenty students handed their assignments
in on time
so these people who are the untimed
people five six of them
that was 20 students okay all right let
me keep going
i'm gonna answer both questions together
okay how many students were in the class
and how many students were late in
handing in their assignments
okay i'm gonna look and i'm gonna notice
for instance
there are 6 here and 5 16. so how much
bigger is this number than this number
how much bigger is this number than this
number
it's it's five times bigger isn't it
does that make sense
this null by this fraction is five times
bigger than this one is that okay
that's good but i want i want this
number
right so in order to get that i want it
to be five times smaller
right so i'm gonna go 20 divided by
five that's five times smaller isn't it
that's four that's how many students
were late okay
what was the other question what was the
other question
how many in total wasn't it that's the
uh
on time students plus the late students
that's 24.
okay i'm finished i've answered the
question okay
now they're going down can anyone tell
me
why might i put this in red why don't i
think this is a very good way
to solve it despite the fact that the
answer is right
any suggestions yeah
hmm that's interesting what would take
too long i don't know just like
maybe the other way would be okay there
might be a quicker way all right sure no
i suggest
um
setting out is important can anyone make
any other comments about the setting out
because then you know it's on the right
track here
about this and what's good or bad about
it really yeah
yeah it's just kind of i i would call
this this is what i call
the random number approach because look
at that
it's really just a collection of numbers
none of which have much to do with each
other okay uh it's a bit like
you know a montage of scenes in a movie
and it's like what does this have to do
with this i have no idea
it's kind of it's a bit confusing now
there are some other problems with it
too have a look at this second line with
me
right what does it represent do you
always explain it to you what does it
represent
the second line what's it talking about
hmm yeah like the people who had it in
the
work early yeah good or on time right
this is the um this is the on timeline
but there's a big
glaring problem with the odd timeline
namely
that it's a lie right 5 6
is not equal to 20 right these are not
the same
okay what i meant was five six of the
class was 20 students
okay so this way not a good way to
approach it even the answers are right
i want you to pick up your pins now and
let me show you how i would set it out
okay
now the way i'm going to do it
the way i'm going to do it sadly is not
faster
it's slower okay but i think it's better
and i'm gonna try and make the case for
that in a second
okay i'm gonna follow this same idea but
i'm gonna write it out properly okay
for instance okay there's one sixth at
the front
right what does it mean what does it
stand for it's not just a random number
it's the part of the class that is late
okay so i'm actually going to write that
i know what the number's just floating
around
in space not meaning anything i need
some words there to actually explain
what's going on
okay i'm then going to say
five sixths the class is not late is on
time
okay now i still want to say that 5 6 of
the class
are 20 students but i'm going to provide
words that make sense of that
okay so i'm going to say that equals 20
students can you see how this second
line
is so much more superior to this second
line right because
this is wrong 5 6 is not equal to 20.
okay and not just that you know what 5 6
of what
and 20 of what okay okay there's my
second line right
now how did i put this together where
did this line
why did i do this right well the reason
i did this is because
there are five times as many
on-time students
as late students
okay they're five times as many or
another way of saying that is there five
times
fewer late students than on time
students so
now because of this statement i'm going
to make
this equation it's equal to 4
but now you can see what the 20 divided
by 5 corresponds to
and what the four corresponds to right
the four is the late students
okay so i would say there are four
students
who are late four legs too
okay and you guys might have seen these
three dots before uh it means
therefore i'm trying to put together an
argument here right
because of this therefore this okay
and from there i can say i want to add
them together right
i can say so there are
20 plus four
total students
now can you see the maths is all the
same right
but the way that i've communicated it is
so so
so much clearer okay you can actually
see which parts of
um which numbers are important this is
important because it's the total
students
this is important because the late
student which is what is being asked for
whereas over here
it's kind of like just free-for-all just
have a guess what's the most important
part of it
okay so my point is the maths can be the
same
but the way you communicate it makes a
real
difference